hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today's Thursday you already know
what time it is it's that stream recap
time now this stream wasn't as
jam-packed as last week was basically
what the dead said is that last week it
was pretty big
this week's isn't going to be so much
but next week is going to have a lot
more info and as they said tune in next
week on the Warriors then as there's
going to be a lot more info on the
upcoming changes with season 5 that is
words directly from the devs so once
again stay tuned for next week we're
gonna have tons of stuff to talk about
with season 5 hopefully some good things
but there is a few things I wanted to
add from last video in today's just in
case you missed it and a few other
things that were added so let's get
straight into this so first up just to
remind you of what season 5 is coming
with it's going to come with no heroes
and it's going to be focusing more on
the hero changes and reworks like conker
can say Berserker and Highlander is well
some parry changes lag compensation new
contents and events like we always have
for the week and dedicated servers I
mentioned this in last week's video but
I just wanted to reiterate that just in
case anyone forgot on top of that patch
1.18 is going to be releasing today
there's going to be a patch notes link
to all of it in the description but I
will go over a few things as well as
things that were not listed and those
three things that were not listed are
that some sounds are gonna sound
different according to the devs and new
effects on blocking and parrying and the
vacuum suck bug with ledges was fixed I
don't exactly know what that means but I
do believe is that if you're super close
to an edge and you're getting up like if
your character was knocked down like a
shoe jockey bat or a Raider charge your
character gets up and they have this
weird bug where they just kind of just
go off the edge even though they weren't
maybe that's the thing that they're
talking about but either way that is
going to be fixed are musha's gonna be
getting a little bit of a buff for this
patch he's going to have 30 damage
instead of 25 for his fury unleashed
attack and that attack is also going to
be having uninterruptible Stan's
properties increase the damage of twin
Vipers to 40 instead of 35 and increase
the damage of ringing the bell to 15
from 10 as well as increasing the
stamina damage of ring the bell to 20
instead of 10 and increasing the damage
of the basic side heavy attack from 30
to 25 and as well reducing the startup
of the basic top heavy strike to 600
milliseconds from 700 milliseconds
basically to summarize that he's going
to be getting about five to ten damage
roughly on just about those moves
I mentioned now I'm not an hour Musha
player I don't exactly know what those
moves are in particular but those are
the moves that's going to be getting a
little bit of damage I'm assuming the
devs want more people to continue to use
that instead of the tempest which I
believe is the alternating from side to
top from side to top with or with heavy
and light attacks at once again I don't
play our Musha but I'm assuming the devs
want more people to use his kit instead
of using the same move like I've stated
previously I have already gone over this
patch to know from last week but these
are what the patches are and it's going
to be releasing today if you do want to
see every single thing like I'm saying
there's a lot of bug fixes I don't want
to go over all this this would be a very
long video if you check the link in the
description and you can find the hero
that you like to play the most and
there's probably going to be a bug fix
somewhere so enjoyed that I forgot to
mention this earlier in the video but
I've been seeing a lot of people on
reddit mentioned that conquer superior
block has disappeared and that is
technically true according to the devs
they said that it's supposed to come out
during his rework for season 5 but it
actually accidentally got added in with
the patch 1.18 so I'm not entirely sure
if they're going to disable it and then
enable it back when the Weaver comes in
or they're just going to keep it in
until the Reaper comes in and then just
continue to have it in who knows but
sadly conquer superior block is gone
next up the dance of death game-mode you
I have posted a video with this with
splice during our collaboration and it's
also been obviously the new event for
the past week a lot of people got an
overwhelming positive response the dev
said that and so they're gonna be
extending the timer to Sunday so if he
didn't get a chance to play or you want
to play more of the matches you have
until this Sunday to play it they are
they are going to be taking it away it's
not going to be permanent but they said
that it may return someday and they will
give increased rewards given as they go
on for a while and then lastly to end
the video we have the weekly content it
is a very long video it's a elite
outfits I'd rather not show the elite
outfits I like to show the long video
for the mythic outfits since there are
so many heroes we have to go through 18
but basically it's going to be the air
signs outfit for the Knights
the angry thoughts for the Vikings and
the krill Sheol for the samurai I'm
pretty sure I butchered that last one
but that's going to be the weekly
content it's going to be elite outfits
they're going to be 7000 steel each so
if any of those interest
you definitely go in grab blues and that
is going to be the end of the video guys
thank you all for sticking around and
stopping by we recently broke the 4,000
subscriber mark appreciate the collab
with splice that took me over it shout
out to all the new subs that came from
that I love you guys
shout out to of course all the old subs
for sticking around enjoying the content
but anyway guys if you did like this
video please sure to give it a like
really does help me out subscribe if
you're new I post the four on her news
the leaks the discussions the
informational site a for honor I got
that all covered by two most recent
videos are gonna be popping up on screen
make sure to stay tuned for next week's
video we're gonna have tons of new info
on season 5 details of stuff that we
have yet to learn the Duff we stick
around for that and with that guys have
a great rest of your day and peace out